he used to call me of jackin Scanlon
crazy man
shotgun Joe and stuff like this they
guys they gave me these Dame's because
of one reason cuz I was crazy you know
that's what people thought I was
attacked always funny and crazy and
stuff the other reason was because um i
was just i bought a shotgun and I sawed
it off and people saw me carrying a
shotgun and that's how I got you know
you know this name you know shotgun Joe
and I came up here they guys in here in
this institution called me a shack and
Joe
my mother will have this guy named buck
and uh one night he let me used the car
and his lady pulled and I was falling
asleep in back and as we got into this
intersection I thought she was going to
kept keep on going
I was I was high and I was really [ __ ]
up you know and here going and lady put
on her brakes and and my reaction was
slow and I hit her in the back the car
spun around and I had the car spun
around I I think I hit my head or
somebody got back up and I started the
car again I took off down the street
now Department where I lived wasn't too
far I say about 200 yards at the most
you know from my you know where I hit
the lady and I started going on the
street the lady started following me and
another guy got in with her and I got
into another car and he started
following me too if we turned out
Capitol Avenue and we parked there and
the lady was sitting lady jumped out of
a car and said to me uh Sonny come here
and I was gonna run but and maybe and
thought the car was gonna be stolen but
I walked over and she's like I'm gonna
call the cops
but then the other guy who falls her she
waved to him and said uh don't worry you
can go now you know it's alright so she
goes to the telephone booth and I'm
trying to I'm begging her please lady
I'll call a cop don't have any insurance
I didn't tell you I didn't have any
license because if I did she really call
the cops I always had her I said please
I'll give you my address and my
telephone number and everything I was
just gonna be all [ __ ] I was gonna
give her it's gonna be all bull and so
she she walked in telephone booth I was
I was drunk I was scared and she just
picked up the receiver on the fault he
was if I say she was about sixty years
old she just picked up the receiver and
I hit her
I caught her right in the face she felt
right against the telephone booth she
fell down I knocked her cold she fell
down I picked her up put her over my
shoulder her dress was way up till you
can see her legs and everything I picked
her up I coated well I walked about but
from here about 20 feet to the back to
the callicles parked in a parking lot
right
later on the seats
I took the top I took her umbrella put
the umbrella over shut the door and I
took off
oh yeah very friendly G talking about
anything at all I think he's very
friendly
um I walked into the place I was really
far was really high I really [ __ ] up
ahead is my sheikin which was a
sawed-off double-barreled shotgun and I
walked up to it and I walked over to the
person me and my buddy we walked in I
had the shotgun mice I said ladies as a
stick-up lady just throws down the table
and I took the shock and I rammed it I
hit her in the forehead does she put the
cash the money on the cash box had me on
the table and she says to me um what do
you mean is to hold up I said this the
hole up lady yeah there was a certain
certain freshness about him that I
couldn't help but admire and certainly
these are traits even though they might
be in the wrong direction I had at this
time I saw that could be developed in
another he he indicated to me that he
could be somewhat of a leader
we went down this Casa Loma restaurant I
was feel having away down the street
about a half a mile
good 3/4 of a mile and we walked in
there and me and me and another guy and
we walked in there and I saw this guy
yelling out pizza orders you know one
mozzarella to go you know and stuff like
that one route Sorella
to go and so I went over there and
nobody was around
they must've won the back room cuz I
grabbed the microphone I was fool route
the switch and I turn our I went in this
and it started going on so I took the
microphone and I walked right over to
the to the word of them huh everybody's
and I started singing I think was
strangers in the night of
scooby-dooby-doo Scooby dooby and like
everybody was slashed the whole place
was I mean war and I stopped they
started clap and the whole people
started clapping that was excited
because no it was my first uh you know
for an audience everybody's clapped and
everything and so the guy I was
embarrassed as a guy grabbed me and my
buddy had the pizza guy grabbed me
he started running me to these two glass
doors there's one here and open and one
to go into the hallway and the one to go
out again well he got me through one of
them and somehow I grabbed him I turned
him around and I pushed her right
through the glass when I got up on top
oh and I started hitting a bowl full my
buddy came out he slipped not simply
mozzarella all over my hands I'm hitting
them oh oh this guy's left him hey wait
a minute stop stop and everybody's on
the outside they're watching us but you
know people like that they don't they
don't stop you know I mean I like him
personally yeah I like him as a person
that's high I don't dislike any of them
let's put it that way at all dislike
none of the boys the bird's name is
Oscar and the cat's name is Smokey Joe
my sister named it after me and I used
to get my sister's sister mad all the
time by uh taking the cat it was only a
small cat about you know just a kid in I
used to take the cat and put it right in
the bird cage shut the cage
I let the bird run around let the cat
the cat would go after it and try to get
it always take the bird out of the cage
tie its wings together and let it run
for its life all around the place it's
used to the brutal bird can run quick
one had seen how somebody's chased them
then cat used to swing at it
doctor burn across the floor but like I
was saying that too grew up I didn't tie
it down anymore cuz the cat used to go
onto the furniture and wait to it
I open the cage they birdies to walk out
onto the ledge of the cage and the cat
will go after I'm caught in the moth one
time to the kid the bird got caught by
the cat
alright then what about doll right all
right all right now force distinction
character risk so our proper nouns and
come now there's one outstanding
characteristic about a proper noun that
is uh it used to begin with the capital
letter remember that ok Scotland now
what I'd say about a proper now what you
ve knows seal on it you well you know
what's going on
louis long yeah he knows what's going on
yeah yeah I slipped you snip yeah they
just don't Sophia nothing what now
oh I don't know we just went over a pass
it be cool man we're gonna grant off my
foot
ok hi you don't want to stay here and
participate with the stuff nice leg out
of class I want you to tell me one good
reason why you don't want to be in
school that's all I'm interested in
it's not helping okay is it not
happening because you don't want to help
you you're not helping deserve my reason
right yeah Harvey that's the reason you
told me give you one answer right there
you have our reason that is no reason do
I leave them man you might as well get
out of my class in gallon school [ __ ] it
I don't want to come
and let him say digger Kamenka man come
back here come back here Hey look at you
don't throw my chills right here dad
right
no come and pick this [ __ ] up and get
out later baby
when he is among a group he has to keep
up this image and that's a big thing
that's all things consignment oh I see
the utter chaos reigning between his
ears you know and the only kind of thing
they're the only kind of string that I
can see in his behavior is the way he
continually seeks to enhance this image
of being well some kids talk of him as
being a the comedian or some kids
talking with being a hard guy he loves
this image and he builds on at all time
he's inside he's really nothing he has
to keep up this this bravado this this
this hero business constantly the moing
lets up he's nothing I think he has no
grasp whatsoever of what is gonna get
him ahead he is not a dumbbell he is not
a damn fool but he needs help and he's
creative because this kid could tell a
story off the top of his head that is
absolutely fantastic incomplete very
where he says there the kid is great but
in a direction that he's go he's not
gonna live very long because we thought
of his own he's gonna blow him away a
cop or somebody help he wants to lead a
life of crime you know he think he
really dig he wants to read books about
crime in about big time you know and how
don't are you how do you argue with a
guy like that you know when you sit
there and you say look you know it's
really bad crimes badge no and you feel
like a fool Satan says well you know it
some people think business some people
think being a lawyer and I have picked
Enoch a criminal he's a loser yeah this
thing he doesn't see that showing other
people off if I'm here what he's a loser
yeah he's loose but a good leader
all right toning the kids and telling me
soon-jong fight you carry on you know a
lot of times down to school you know
he'll come up to me and say uh well I
don't like you I'm gonna hit you know it
just brought around right
see y'all all set for a fight and then
I'll settle come up with a joke but he
makes your time go by easier you know me
hyper kid that you can't help but like
sometimes with sometimes you you just
can't take it's too much I think he's
just a nerd you know as far as you know
even chocolate Mountain know he goes out
into society and that he wants to go you
know do the same thing I don't think
he's serious you know I think nobody
could be serious bump on my godson do
the same thing you know they got you
here the first time I don't know it just
a little mixed up like me I think it's
pretty mixed up fly self to him but he
doesn't have he's got everything gone
wrong with me he's got wrong on the ball
he's got an image thing here anyway I
don't know him on a bridge but I hear
he's got an image thing that he tries to
maintain you know he tries to keep cool
and canals like he eat he's fat honest
with himself as he should be man he
should look at himself as oh man where
are you going with
Oh
[Music]
October November December January
February March April May 3rd 1970 it is
a long time is it October November he
summer be here Christmas Salvation Army
comes in and plays the old band movie
you know yeah
New Year's you know this is a South
Block here you know and you know from
the camera is it's gonna be showing on
people think you know you can go right
through these these windows you know if
you wanted to get out of something you
know but uh you're not gonna get out
because you're still reinforcements all
here the window as you think you see it
you're not gonna get to it it it's it's
solid steel hallway and if you put a
cheer or anything in it you're you could
forget about it cuz only only way you're
ever gonna get two years is this a crane
a ball don't right through here that's
only way you gonna get through I get
three meals a day Eric food relaxation
there's nothing better than being on
that brick nothing better and walk down
the street no for him I want to see that
zone he was only one reason I want to go
on the back to Street in this darkness
the car truth I want to take care of my
sisters my sister probably take care of
Betty and too but I want to take care of
him
I really do I took here before I want to
take care of McGann
when I get out there hey [ __ ] yeah
oh yeah to get what they want our steel
form now steel form I every bit of money
I gave them was either stolen or maybe
if I had a job I get but the big money I
gave like seven
eighty ninety dollars to buy clothes
when they'll verify this
it was hot money May but neither Tom was
hot I love that girl
I give her anything any [ __ ] thing
anything she [ __ ] wanted she's got Oh
shaking a hole what it's like my prayer
book I get them every month their
monthly missile at Penn I'm an altar boy
he doesn't want to know about we huh big
[ __ ] I'll read a couple to hear him up
one read one from our [ __ ] moms but I
want to read a letter from my sister are
you getting out this January she's
annoying another bid that would miss
Bush told me so in your next letter I
want you to tell me so I'll know um if
there's anything you want when I come up
or any any more questions you won't
answer you just write tell me Joe don't
worry about me I've been a good girl and
I'm then I am ever and I'm always in the
house head or I didn't sow so don't
worry Betty Ann told me to tell you that
she loves you Joe I got to clean the
house so write soon and don't ever
forget I love yous in this issue
miss you bye-bye your sister Diana I
miss you a lot Joe and Diana forever
brother no doubt about it I love you
brother thank good huh wait let me find
you know it's hard finding these letters
Audrey Bush my social worker dear Joe he
has got no [ __ ] right to call me dear
it's mr. Scanlon right cuz I don't
respect her she respect me I'm not that
close word I thought I would drop you a
short note you know look how long the
notice to let you know how things are
going I know you've been aware your
mother was hospitalized during later
part of August I don't want to know
about this crap cause I don't care about
my mother
I don't have nothing on nothing doing
her she is now back home stone close
contact with dr. Blasco alias alias mr.
Hyde we had been trying to work out a
ride for her to Cheshire I told him that
I told him I didn't want no way to come
see me but my sister Unferth
unfortunately she was hospitalized me to
not carry through on this plan thank God
peace was on fourth of July I never
forgot he won a lawsuit puts a new car
23000 he didn't give me no money just
took joy for the weekend say be back he
never came back to jump kids and love
money to have a good time in Disneyland
yeah I never could find Cho say came
back wasn't the same anymore no what
makes him that way today he was always
good to me
like I say he took me away when I was
about um about five five or six I
remember I was just gonna go to school
he took me out of a car accident took me
to Californian of that and [ __ ] like
that
how the $1,600 was 2,600 2,600 car
accident I psyched up back when he was
12 years old and he was all disturbed
and the woman I used to take care of
home mr. pullings hair used to put him
in a corner and I never knew that so we
had to please warn all the state to find
with the husband is to take Joe home so
Joel came home give me more with the
mother
I used to say your mother was dead and I
never forgot
well the first risk was my mother says I
hit her here I wouldn't at first she
told me to leave the house and tells me
not to leave the house but finally I
said okay I'm packing up and everything
and there's a big argument the house and
mother and they said they said I struck
her but I didn't strike her this day -
those state isms happened 67 I think it
was I didn't strike her and so on
downstairs they call the cops the cops
came my mother's all upset
she started saying I hit or an every
[ __ ] thing my sisters were crying
they denied it my mother yeah I want him
arrested for assault he hit me [ __ ] fine
thanks the doorman is angry but you
never put a hand on me you know your
walks away again you comes back as her
mom sobbing they don't find I said [ __ ]
preach a piece by assault $10 fine
$15 fine that was all right when the
court I pleaded guilty they gave me nine
months stage of 16 in jail nine months
do you like to mama you start begging
the daughter don't call me a liar
turn your tool so he got mad he fainted
or nywhere not started cool off then he
comes back and sit down and he put his
head down he starts crying do you hear
your mother so much you know well on her
stick I mean in a hospital most six
times the heart attack a blood pressure
I worry too much about my Joe always
worried the doctors I wrote too much
about him
I never had a chance to save some if I
man in the hospital I'm moving better
take easy I can't go so far away gonna
have a heart attack she called the cops
I mean pick up the phone and call the
cops
well I went out with the four out of the
wall I read back of my routine well I
walked back to my room she kept on
yelling I told want you go to sleep girl
lady has heart for a while as hearts for
when she's nervous as [ __ ] like that and
she'll use that as a crutch for herself
I love Joe again maybe think he wanted
you didn't have to go and steal it I
didn't have it I just didn't have it
it's all live without it he's a tough go
what and get to satisfy me but I didn't
believe the idea I didn't like the idea
alone I knew he's doing something wrong
when he comes home late the ice I'm just
like the father says I'm do just like
your old man she says I don't think my
father ever got busted I'm not quite
sure I think so maybe but um I don't
think I'm like my own
I used to come on four o'clock in the
one is where you've been always friends
up there was stealing left of mine
that's how he got the money and I never
knew it I don't know I just don't care
about money well anymore I love her
where she's not gonna hurt me like she
did so many [ __ ] years that's for
sure
bloke I told him in the brothers my
letters you can't explain the kind of
feeling that I have for him he just has
to know that I love them no I'll never
childhood yeah I saw a shrink Monday
ages I just worry too much I keep my
Prague's on side he says the best thing
for Joe and I think for all of us like
is that when my brother comes out I know
for definite that I'm going to go with
them I mean that means if Joe gets in
trouble I'm going to be there too is why
should my brother get time you know when
everybody else is sitting home because
it's just hurting him or knowing that
wall sit in love like having a good time
I'm going out and everything and he's
not doing that
what is he locked up in some damn place
every time I think about my mother for
father's sister no rosemary are anything
that on anything I pisses me off I just
go out on the Mac I go into another mood
and I'm not funny no more I don't pull
around the more you take away
you take away
you will sit at the right hand of the
cloud efforts gonna you alone are alone
our Lord
father aina Lord be with you I'm not
going to be too wanted to make sure what
I can do if I if I throw up I'm afraid I
might hurt somebody there goodbye bloop
against you I kill you
that's why I write out I don't stop I
just keep going and keep going you know
that might hurt somebody I know I I hit
my sister one time I let go one time I
hit my system in a sideline plus the two
or [ __ ] ribs no more no more hair can
we stop this that wasn't that's myself
okay yeah yeah I don't like to be sad
that's all I like to think and always
I'd like to be happy at the all the time